so Starbucks came out with this smoked
butterscotch latte and everybody on the
internet is saying that it's basically
butter beer so we're gonna try it and
figure out if that's true
I'm not a fan of Harry Potter I love
everything Harry Potter I am a Potter
head Harry Potter is literally life if
one more person or book wants to
convince me that the chosen one is some
basic white guy I'm gonna slap them
across the face butterbeers a beer from
Hogwarts
I'm assuming it's like butterscotch and
a little bit of heaven I have tried the
actual butter beer at the whizzing roll
Harry Potter is Butterfield like a Harry
Potter thing I so don't know about our
ears what is this Jesus
this is gonna change your life you're
gonna read the books after this it looks
like something from Starbucks yeah
cheers Cheers Tudor better beer and
great engrossed in the childhood bed bed
okay this already doesn't smell like
butter beer it's got that like
butterscotch e flavor it's so I could
see why people would say it's like
butter beer this is nothing like the
butter beer that I tried at Harry Potter
world it just tastes like butterscotch
okay so this isn't quite butter beer
from the whizzing world of harry potter
which i think is the closer that you can
get to the book but I do like this drink
click Andy it's great I think this is as
disappointing as Harry Potter so it's
consistent with the legacy of Kirsty
with my spells it's more about just like
imposing the fandom on to the end yeah